jeopardy fans are still reeling from the
loss of alex trebek the classic game
show
is actually going back into production
over on the sony lot with all-time champ
ken
jennings at the helm i can't imagine
jeopardy
hosted by anybody else to me he's
irreplaceable the 46-year-old former
engineer will be the first of several
guest hosts and starts work on monday
those episodes start airing january 11th
and jennings appears to be the
front-runner to replace alex trebek
permanently
back in september he joined jeopardy as
a consulting producer
but don't count out the competition just
yet i love
jeopardy i can just watch it and get
away from it all comedian dane cook
tweeted he got a call about guest
hosting and replied quote
i could barely spit out what is yes
quick enough
and jane lynch was asked if she would be
up for the job
i would do it in a new york minute but i
also i've been reading on twitter
they've been bouncing names around and i
thought levar burton would be very good
she's not alone as of today more than a
hundred thousand people have signed a
change.org petition for levar
to take over the job wow wow
in response he tweeted even if nothing
comes from it i appreciate all y'all's
love and support the 63 year old hosted
reading rainbow for 23 years
and while jeopardy's executive producer
isn't commenting on alex's successor
he did say trebek wanted a season pro he
talked a lot about
that it needs to be someone that the
audience will respect
that's believable in the role has
credibility
other names in the mix two news anchors
george stephanopoulos
would you take that job i think it would
be a lot of fun but i like what i'm
doing too and
anderson cooper who's been a contestant
on celebrity jeopardy
three times i feel like i have so much
ridiculous information in my head
that it's nice to be tested on it uh
back to ken jennings more good news for
him because
today he's also a grammy nominee ken was
nominated for best spoken word
album for voicing alex's book the answer
[Music]
is